thanks SJ hello and welcome to the Daily
climate show coming up today
more than 650 scientists urge world
leaders to stop destroying the lungs of
the Earth by burning trees to make
energy
the UN campaign to improve soil health
and management across the globe as the
organization marks World soil day
and the British Red Cross says the UK is
ill-prepared for floods as wet weather
becomes more common
foreign
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis more than 650 scientists are
calling on world leaders including Rishi
sunac to stop burning trees to create
energy because it destroys the lungs of
the planet well ahead of the cop-15
biodiversity Summit this week scientists
from every continent wrote to leaders
about the devastating impact of
bioenergy on habitats creating bioenergy
involves cutting down trees and burning
them to generate electricity and they
want major users which include China the
US and the UK to ditch the energy source
all together
well as you can see here from our
climate data dashboard more than five
percent of the UK's electricity is
currently being fueled by biomass
our climate reporter Victoria Seabrook
has more
now this is all about bioenergy which
has long been a controversial form of
energy because it involves cutting down
trees and using parts of them to
generate electricity albeit planting new
trees in their place but more than 600
scientists have written to selected
world leaders urging them to ditch this
energy source because of what they say
is a devastating impact on nature so the
UK prime minister Rishi sunak is one of
those name checked in the letter because
the UK is such a big consumer of this
form of energy it provides something
like 13 of our electricity but the
scientists are saying this is having an
impact on nature that we just can't
afford it's not just about the trees but
all of the other benefits that they
bring you're also losing the Moss which
helps to slow flooding or the fact that
these forests provide habitats for
things like birds and insects which are
pollinated eating our crops that are
making our food and this letter lands
just before high stakes International
negotiations start this week in Canada
to try to reverse the unprecedented loss
of nature that we're seeing around the
world at the moment this is happening
alongside and and linked with the
climate crisis one million species at
risk of Extinction and what they're
saying is that efforts to reverse the
decline of Nature and protect certain
areas of land is going to be undermined
if we're also cutting down forests at
the same time now as I said this is a
very controversial and divisive form of
energy because you've also got a group
of sign a significant group of
scientists who say well actually by uh
actively managing the forest in this way
we can help to suck up carbon and and
ensure that these habitats are protected
so certainly very divisive and this will
feature at these negotiations which will
be talking about how to protect the
world's land
well as Victoria was saying there cop 15
starts on Wednesday this week but what
is it and how does it differ to the
other climate Summit held in Egypt just
last month well its official title is
the 15th Conference of the parties to
the United Nations convention on
biological diversity last month's cop 27
Summit was focused on climate change of
course whereas cop 15 this week focuses
on bringing the Earth's biodiversity
under control it was scheduled to take
place in quinming in China two years ago
but was postponed because of the
pandemic the first part took place
online in October last year where
delegates committed to put the world's
biodiversity on a path to recovery by
2013.
now although China retains its
presidency the second part of the
meeting has now moved to the Canadian
city of Montreal and will take place
from this Wednesday until Monday the
19th of December and we will of course
keep you right across the latest
developments throughout the summit
okay well let's take a look at what else
is making climate news today for you and
the UK is ill prepared to respond to
floods caused by climate change that's
according to the British Reds cross a
new report from the Charities says that
almost three and four people living in
an area where floods are likely don't
know they're actually at risk well it
comes as experts warn the number of
properties in England at risk of
flooding from heavy rainfall in the next
30 Years could double
now more than 2 500 seals have been
found dead on the Caspian Sea Coast in
southern Russia the cause of the deaths
isn't yet known and the head of the
Caspian Environmental Protection Center
said there was no sign they were killed
or caught in fishing nets Caspian seals
have been classified as endangered since
2008.
a climate change protester who blocked
the Sydney Harbor Bridge has been
sentenced to 15 months in prison for
disrupting Russia rush hour traffic
Deanna Violet Coco was one of four
protesters from the activist group
fireproof Australia who blocked a lane
on the bridge back in April well today
the New South Wales Premier described a
sentence as pleasing to see but
unofficial Clement wall said he was
alarmed by the co-op's decision
now today is World soil day an
international initiative led by the UN
to highlight the importance in
maintaining healthy ecosystems and
climate change mitigation well according
to the organization the equivalent of a
football pitch is lost due to soil
erosion every 15 seconds putting major
strains on Global Food security
well 95 of our food comes from soils 18
naturally occurring chemical elements
are essential to plant soils Supply 15
of those now agricultural production
will have to increase by 60 percent to
meet the global food demand in 2050. 33
percent of soils are degraded meaning
the level of nutrients and vitamins in
food is drastically decreased and using
fewer chemical pesticides covering bare
soil with crops that stay in leaf for
longer and adding compost could help
sustainably manage soil and produce up
to 58 percent more crops
well to Mark worlds all day the soil
Association are encouraging people to
get dirty for nature and climate and
take selfies with soil head of PR at the
charity Pete Williams joins me now hi
Pete good to have you with us um let's
let's talk about just how important soil
is to all of us and it's not just
agricultural is it it's also the
ecosystem for the world
absolutely it may be just dirt under our
feet but soil is essential to life on
Earth and it holds the answer to the
combined climate nature crisis
and um why does it hold the answer to
tackling the combined nature and climate
crisis what why is why is it so crucial
to both Pete
well soil does many things but healthy
soil uh actually locks away carbon it
protects us from floods and droughts and
also very importantly it provides the
world with healthy food
um Pete tell me about seven-year-old
soil Guru anishwa kunshala
all right kunchala I wrote The Fame uh
on Britain's Got Talent but he is a real
soil Guru and um we've teamed up with
him to actually help
um educate the Next Generation about the
importance of soil health and he's
joined us to demonstrate some really uh
inspiring and engaging soil science
experiments so we can see why it's so
important to the farmers to do things
like cover crop and to actually
sustainably manage our soils so that
they protect us and provide us with
healthy food right into the future how
do they do that how do farmers do that
and how do we do that how do we get it
right
but there's many things we can do and
and you've gone through some of those
already but composting planting our own
uh choosing organic foods and buying
local food so maybe signing up to a
local box game these are all simple
things we can do at home but we need the
policy makers both here in the UK and
across the world to step up to the
challenge we've known this for long
enough but it's essential that the cop
15 in Montreal that they they start to
take the steps that are going to protect
our soil and actually ensure that we can
tackle the climate crisis and also
protect biodiversity and Pete finally
you're asking people to take selfies
with their hands up but tell us more
about that what what I think the hands
have to have dirt on them right
that's it we're asking everybody to roll
up their sleeves uh on World Tour they
uh get dirty for nature and actually
just hold up the hand take a selfie
photo or a video and just say why soil
is important it locks away carbon it
protects us from floods and droughts and
it helps feed the world uh that's all it
is we just wanted everybody to share it
with friends and family so we all
understand how important its soil is and
that the policy makers actually sit up
and listen and act
now
okay I'll make a pledge Pete I'll do
that for you thanks very much indeed for
joining us Pete Williams from the world
soil Association
that's all from me and the team here
thanks very much for watching
[Music]